Good morning.
So I'm here with good news because we will
all be game programmers very soon.
So, I'm sure a lot of you like myself got
into programming in the first place because
you wanted to build the next Mario N the decade
it turns out I build a lot more banking apps
than Mario.
I'm glad it's head bog a dire where we can
integrate elements from video games into our
apps soon.
Not only do I think these techniques are useful
that we can get from game development patterns,
you'll integrate a few of these thing in the
next couple of years.
This might make a little bit more sense if
I explain my double life.
During the day I'm the no guy at Heroku, when
ever any you file a note ticket, when ever
the build pack doesn't work I get yelled at,
when people are confused at the Dev documentation,
that's my fault,i'm sorry this is my serious
work, this is the work that I do that people's
livelihood depend on.
And so it's kind of a scary, slow development
work that I do I do from 9‑5
are literally thousands of production apps
that people are earning a living with that
I can look at and compare, how people are
following different patterns, how some companies
are successful, while some aren't.
There's an interesting talk later how Toyota
Europe is going to‑‑ is running right
now on Heroku, that's by ray Mcdermit, you
should check it out.
I have a unique insight on how people are
building Java apps these days because I see
so many of them every day.
That's my day job, at night I work in a less
serious way, I work on playful Java script,
it doesn't have a purpose or point, it's JavaScript
techniques that aren't going to help you pass
questions when you're interviewing for a job,
nothing that people teach at university.
It's stuff I've been interested in since I
was a kid,games, graphics, audio, I play with
things like procedural generation, I play
with stuff like old school 3 D rendering techniques,right,
and then, occasionally, very occasionally,
some crazy company will pay me to build a
game in HTML five, this is a bigger and bigger
thing a couple of years ago this wouldn't
happen.
Nobody would say, hey you build me a game
in JavaScript.
I'm excited about this, I think it will keep
on exceller rating, this is the basis for
the talk.
And, I'm not an E.
pert, right, so I play with things at night,
I am an expert at note and running note apps,
this is just my hobby, time not a game developer
by trade, I love this stuff, and I think more
of us are going to become developers by trade
over the next couple of years, even if not,
it's fun to learn, right, and something I
think everybody should try at least once .
so, first, why should JavaScript developers,
even care what game developers do?
It seems like we're worlds a part, they write
thing in C plus plus while we write in interpretative
language, we're writing on bare metal, and
we oar trap in the a browser and they're concerned
with players while we're concerned with users,
doesn't seem like there's a whole lot of overlap
here.
To answer that question, let me take you way,
way back to 2008, when J query was still new
and popular with everybody.
And this is Google maps, in 2008 as usual,
pushing I limits of JavaScript this was a
cutting edge App, from our current perspective,
you can see it was a little bit better than
map quest, 2 dimensional, not a lot of interactivity
here.
Now, here's 2008's grand theft auto, same
year, but different piece of software, instead
206 D top down camera, you is 3‑D moving
cam remarks full textures and shadows, tabbed
geometric detail on building is incredible.
It's a far cry from the Google maps of the
same era.
Okay.
The four years later Google released an update
to Google maps, in this new version, you have
the 3 D textures geometric details and dynamic
shadows, that bringe brings me to the question
if you had to put some money on which one
of these three apps is most similar, twoe
which two have the most similar architecture
in my money would be on these two.
So even though it's the same App, the Google
maps of 2013 is a lot closer to a video game
grand theft auto of 2008 than to it's predecessor,
similar anyely in 2004, anyone den do touch
was a big hit.
Pioneered what touch can do as a core interaction
element.
And then in 2007, the iPod touch was also
a big hit.
And apple is clearly responsible for the fact
that nobody younger than me even knows how
to use a screen that you can't touch and drag
things on.
But even though apple is responsible for making
it ubiquitous, touch was really pioneer in
the the games industry.
And, do any of you remember moon patrol?
Really,?!
>> Great.
>> Because I was one‑year‑old when this
came out, so I don't remember moon patrol,
according to Wikipedia, it was the game that
pioneered Paralax, as you move the background
scrolled at different speeds to give you an
illusion of depth.
Now you can't go anywhere without seeing Parallax,
you can't hit a stone without hitting somebody
that put Parallax on their site, sometimes
for guide and sometimes for bad,you know you
R decades ago something that became prevalent
if games is now becoming popular in the web,
this is something you see over and over that
games lead all other technologies and push
boundaries that we then come in and get to
fill, once it's easier to do.
Today's game experience leads to tomorrow
experience.
If you want to see what apps of tomorrow is
going on you should look at games today.
How they're using to expect interfaces to
behave.
So ...
you can see a lot of other examples, I've
given several, every time you use Google docks,
you're now sharing virtual environment, this
is what games have been doing for decades,
now document services are starting to it to,
and it's like a big deal.
So it's important for everybody to learn,
of course, I'm not the first person to realize
we can learn a lot from game developer, getting
spammed by Fam.us, it's a gum engine that
allows you the run apps on top of it.
Chucked the MVC framework and said we're going
to build a crappy game engine, that's what
people are running interesting interactive
apps with great success.
This is my favorite example of how games and
Annes are colliding at least in scheme, this
is the architecture for doom 3, the important
part is the second and third step, the second
step, the scene IR, it builds the description
of the seen, what you're look at, what you
can see, what's in the frame, what's local
your character, and fourth step is where it
renders it, reverending something in 3 D costs
a lot, which operations you chose to render
are actually really important, they can make
your frame rate faster or slow, in doom 3,
they actually figure out exactly which operations
they need to pass to the reverend before they
render anything to make the application run
as quickly as possible this is what I think
is really Fucking school, reactjs works the
same way, the architecture is identical, so
instead of opening jail though the bottle
next is the DOM, they build a scene, they
do a full scene builder before they run to
the DOM that way the scene builder can compute
which DOM is faster to render, they're pulling
ideas straight out of the world of game development.
So it's inevitable.
You're probably already using some of this
stuff today, if you're not, I guarantee you
will be, I think this is a great opportunity
to become familiar with patterns that game
developers have been using for decades, when
you build your next App you can have them
in your tool set that's the argument for using
game techniques inside of apps, the other
reason you might want to know about game Dev
you might want to build a game, I have great
news, there's never been a better time to
build games with JavaScript, we have all the
basic primitives we need in the form of web
APIs to start competing toe to toe with real
native experiences the gap thee between JavaScript
is closing rapidly.
I'm really excited about this, so this begs
the question: Why isn't everybody doing this?
Some people are trying, some early pioneers,
this is a gum called poly craft, really Polished
3 D game belt in JavaScript, you've probably
seen cut the rope, probably one of the most
well known HTML 5 game to date.
And the reason that there aren't many successful
story s is that we lack familiarity, tooling
and marketplace.
Game develops have a huge tool sets have familiarity
with how game are built, and marketplace,e
to ship things, we don't have any of these
things, I can't address all of these, I'll
provide a little familiarity to a group of
JavaScripters who might be interested in build
ago game one day.
We'll look at a couple of web game development
techniques, we're going to look at it specifically
in JavaScript, all of these techniques can
be applied to apps, it takes a little bit
more creativity to did that, they can push
things forward.
So,the first part earn to look at when ever
you're‑‑ pattern to look at is the game
loop this is basic core fundamental behind
any game since video games were a thing.
This is sort of code that you probably would
not get through code review at most shops,
right, it's a wild loop that never stops,
has some conditionals in it, and you're just
doing everything in this waterfall pattern,
but this is what's powering every game you've
ever used.
And the reason for that is because it makes
time explicit,right, the issue with traditional
event‑based architecture that we're using
in games now, you have an event, a click event,
it triggers some kind of re"A," you closed
a window or moved to the next screen, the
time is implicit in that, an event happened
and then you give a response, you know the
response happened after the vent, you never
elevate time to a first class citizen, you
never measure time to the point where you
can put so it a variable, and that's what
a game loop gives you, it lets you measure
time between different iter rations of the
loop and store time into a variable.
The other thing that it lets you the is keep
moving without user input, you're just responding
strengths, you're deopinion didn't entirely
on the user to push your game forward and
push any elements on the game forward and
with the game loop you can respond to time
and send it to user so you don't just have
are too have aen an action and reaction pattern,
I have two demos that will illustrate this.
So let's go here.
So, this is a version of a small simple game
I hope it doesn't blow anybody's Ears.
So this is a game that only runs, there's
no loop here, just listening to my input and
responding to the input.
If I start pressing keys, it will start dog
things, and I can move and and I can jump
and whatever.
But then, as soon as I stop, nothing happens,
I could be in the middle of a jump, and it's
just there, so trying to build a game, using
MVC, if we try to use backbone, this is basically
what would happen, this is‑‑ you're
entirely dependent on the user for everything
in this environment, right, so as soon as
the user ...
stops doing anything, your game is sort of
pointless, right, and this is not just true
with games, this is true with anything that
requires physics and motions beyond something
that you're responding to, when you see a
bounce effect or nice physical scroll, flick
an icon, it has the same problem so that's
without an vent loop F you go with an vent
loop, this is exactly the same game, but it's
just going to keep running no matter what,
I can stop doing anything and everything still
works, I'll still fall, the environment is
still going to be alive, right, this is one
hundred percent due to the vent loop, there's
no other difference between the two games,
I copied and pasted it.
That's how important an vent loop is to rich
interactive dynamic applications.
So, let me kill that so the music stops.
And then ...
cool.
So once you've got a game loop you quickly
run into a problem, the problem is you're
starting to pack all the log bog the one game.
Once you have more than one or two different
entities you're trying up to date with time,
they start to get conflated, you have enormous
thousand line loop and you don't know where
anything is.
In almost every game that's ever been created,
there's an update pattern, this is where you
make your game entities or even just your
graphical entities autonomous, you teach them
how to handle their own changes through time.
Right, and you can see here, it's just an
anywheretional pattern, not doing anything
differently, organizing it in a sane way.
And this is important because that way your
player can know how to walk and how far he
needs to walk depending on how much time has
passed.
Clouds can move with the wind and when you
flicke flick an icon, it knowtion how to keep
sliding across the screen without any sort
of direction from the main game loop.
We all know the decoupling is a good idea,
this is one of the primary ways that decouping
is done in games that have to do with time
and not just the user.
The other cool thing is like a light form
of deopinion den say injection, you don't
have to pass time to these things, you can
pass other arguments they may depend on.
And the final thing that you need to know
if you're going to ship a game tomorrow, you
need to understand what a time buffer is,
a time buffer is an extension to the traditional
game loop and update cycles and what it does
is instead of treating time in each loop as
an individual entity what you respond, to
every time you get a new instance to a loop,
add time to a buffer, keep packing into a
buffer, when the buffer over flows a certain
amount, which is your frame time, you render
a frame, keep adding to the buffer, when ever
the buffer is bigger than a certain set amount
that you decided on initially you reverend
a frame and clear that time out of the buffer.
This sounds like you might be overcomplicating
things, you a game loop that will let you
process time, this is important for a couple
key reason, it keeps physic models stable,
most physical integration methods like the
one when you see on your iPhone to 3 D video
game will start the feel weird and woning
I can, reverending at different time intervals,
sometimes you're not moving it far enough.
Important for anything that has physics involved,
it decoupings, simulating and reverending,
this is critical you want the use request
animation frame, anything that you want to
be responsive on the web,with the request
animation frame,you know browsers are ready
to rerender the DOM, that might happen at
30 frames per second on one machine and 60
on another, you want them to simulate the
exact same thing at the exact same speed A
time buffer will let you do that, the same
amount of time, over and over and over and
the output, the result of both machines will
be the same, even if they render different
number of frames, this is kind of hard to
explain, so, I've put together a little demo
of it.
One of the projects I worked on is called
Newton, it's a physic engine no one should
use because I wrote it to learn how it works.
You replicate time‑based behavior that's
what a time buffer allows you the do, no matter
how p times I rerun the same simulation it
will happen the exact same way every time,
you can run automated tests, this is important
when you want to use game technique s is an
App, you want to use automated tests in an
App.
Let me open up this example this is Newton,
it's a little embarrassing because what I
was try dog in this particular version of
Newton was just to make a stable box, like
that was the whole goal.
Literally make a box that doesn't implode
on itself, this was version 500 of that attempt
because I really suck at math what kind of
sucks but what's also cool is that when it
first starts the box seems to be able, then
something happens it to, favorite bug I ever
created in any software ever.
Here we go I'm going to refresh it if the
interin the works.
(Laughing) I couldn't build this if you asked
me to, right.
(Anews) that's the crazy part, it becomes
a abortion, it stabilize, it will never do
that again.
Trust me, I've tried, it'll keep on bouncing
back and forth, back and forth.
What's really cool about, this because it's
using a time buffer, I can refresh this as
many times as I want and every single time
it will behave exactly same way.
No different, right, you can compare the different
frames they would be identical.
And it doesn't matter what computer, you can
put it on an iPhone, and put next to a computer,
it will run at exact same speed, this is a
combination of the game loop‑‑ it allows
me to reproduce a bug, I love this bug.
So I don't want to group too long, let's put
a little bit of this together.
The game I put together, the one that looks
like a Shiy version of mine craft, this is
an vent loop, I copied and pasted it.
Not come plait, full published game, you can
finish it, it has music, audio, upgrades,
but like this is the full vent loop.
So, it can keep things like tight and simple,
one of the nicest things I think about an
vent loop is after building all sorts of backbones,
spaghetti apps over the years, I love that
an event loop, lexically encode shows you
what you're doing over and over and over,
it really highlights the hot spots in your
code for you, if something is goening wrong
or slow, it's because of something deep inside
of your vent loop.
You can see the game loop, the time buffer,
and update method working together.
The whole function is the loop, this frame
is called over and over and over with a request
animation frame.
That time buffer is just a bit at the top,
a clock system that they just impresents a
time buffer, does what it says, adds time
to it, over flows a certain amount, extracts
that amount out, over and over and over, nothing
special.
You see a bunch of update method, updating
the control, the player, it's updating the
music.
And, like, that's the whole thing, that's
all you really need make a game.
And so, where do you go next?
I obviously just showed you the very basics
of building a game, I hope some of you guys
will go home and join one of the 48 hour competition
and try throwing something together .
These are some really good resources if I
was going to put a game together with JavaScript,
they're simple, short, mature, fun, well documented,
right, that you can rely on the build things
like 2 D graphics, 3 D graphics, physics you
can use my Heroku, to build some really awesome
multiplayer stuff.
If you want to talk about any of this Nerdy
stuff, Hunter at Heroku.com, thank you (applause)
from
>> If you have questions, it'll be at our
booth where every one was having breakfast,